hey everybody it's grandmaster ben
feingold here with uh game of the day
it's my first game of the day uh
in 2021 that wasn't from the candidates
which recently finished
this is from the russian team
championship premier league the highest
league
um and here we have
possibly the game of the year but that
would be
i guess for you guys to decide if you
think it is um this game was played
earlier today
uh may 1st in round one and if this is
round one
i can't wait to see round two so let's
have a look at the game
um white's rating is about 300 points
higher than blacks
white's like 2680 and black as an im
white's gm
so you expect white to win just
not like this okay so they played
actually a line
that i play shocking um i play
with black i play e6 i play knight e7
and here i either face c3 or rookie one
those are the common moves
i have faced d4 it's happened
take take and i play queen b6 and
i think most of my opponents have played
here maybe all of them
and um i think in blitz chess and bullet
chess and slow chess
i i've played all three moves but i've
never played queen takes b5
um uh magnus has played b
takes c6 as well as jeffrey jean and
other top gm's so i'm
not gonna argue with that in fact next
time i have this position maybe i'll
play b take c6
okay bishop to d3 and they followed
a game that karawana won against lenach
about i don't know three or four years
ago
um which went this way a lot of games
went this way
jeffrey jean when he played wesley so he
played bishop c5
um bishop e7 is also a common move
and this position has been reached
for uh five times in my database
and white one three and drew two
so that's back to the drawing board for
black
the engine says black's okay but it
prefers white this is a very nice
positional move
because it makes it awkward for the
d-pawn to move because you can take on
poisson and ruin the pawn structure
and it makes it awkward for this bishop
because it can't get out
um so here black played a novelty i
don't know if it's a prepared novelty
um everybody heretofore
has played d5 and the engine doesn't
like that move and black played e5
so e5 is okay um you know controls f4
maybe you'll get the bishop out later if
you're lucky take some control of the
center
all right so bishop e3 completing
development
knight f4 unfortunately
knight f4 helps you
understand white's plan the reason he
played knight here in pawn here
wasn't just to you know sort of crunch
black
but also to get the c4 square available
for the bishop
so white didn't really mind the black
played knight f4
okay so the engines all say white's a
little bit better
and i think if you asked a super gm
human
they would say differently at least i
would
white's doing really well here and one
of the reasons is
not only is white better and has more
space and this bishop is
terrible and black is really passive
but it's really difficult to play black
and it's really easy to play white
white has the half open file white can
attack on the king's side
um i don't know what black's plan is i
don't know
okay so black played rigged g8 that's
fine
queen f3 and
now the engines are starting to like
white but it's just really hard to play
black
probably it's time to play d5 and even
though white's better
black can get a little space um but he
played knight e6
not a i don't know just black just can't
move anything
rook fd1 uh
i mean it's just very difficult to find
a plan for black
he's sort of getting squished and
squished
okay now i don't know if he's lost here
like if two super computers were playing
i think white would win so maybe black
is already lost
after bishop f6 he's definitely lost
i said this bishop was bad with this
bishop yeah
so maybe i won't play this for black all
right
he played queen g3 um
good move knight f4
he just he just came from f49 f4 knight
e6 knight f4
okay now the engines want to play rook
d2
to double up on the bubble up and also
it stops this forever this is stopping
it forever
but black actually should have played
differently in the game and then white
would have had more issues
played rook d6 which is definitely what
i would play
and after bishop e7 he just
said i'll sacrifice the exchange i watch
ben feingold's stream all the time
is that what he said okay and black only
has one move to survive here
and that is to play rook to b4 which he
did not play
and the idea is i want to take this
bishop
and then play knight e2 check winning
the queen and even if i
can't play knight e2 check winning the
queen i still want to take this bishop
i'm sacrificing the exchange but the
pawns are bad
the bishop isn't crushing me and this
bishop can't go to asic
can go to a6 now actually i want to do
this even if that e2 check isn't
available
um he didn't find that after rook here
the engine
really likes white but not like winning
winning just much better
instead he made definitely the losing
move bishop takes d6
now he's i mean now you got four bad
pieces and one that could be captured
that's not good now not only the piece
is bad
black has to play uh you know his queen
a really terrible square
either a5 or b7 obviously a5
looks better but after bishop d2
then you have to play rook b4 and humans
aren't going to do that
so you play queen b7 which is just
terrible
the move is not terrible just the
position's terrible queen g5
threatening meeting one and white wants
to play queen here attacking this
so black stopped him
with rookie eight and there's two
really brilliant moves this game and
this is the first one
um and this is enough to make it a great
game
after this move it's a great game uh
queen e7
and this actually reminds me of the game
etsy on back pro versus vishy anand
i don't know 20 years ago 25 years ago
in a rapid tournament
where back row played rookie one to stop
queen e2
then a nun played queen e2 and bacro
resigned
because the rook couldn't take the queen
because of some checkmates like here
um so the obvious idea is if you take
and i take
as lizza would say the truth hurts
you can't stop ea queen there's nothing
to do
okay now this is threatened and this is
threatened
obviously if he saw rookie queen e7
black would have played rook f8 which
also loses
because his pawn's hanging so he tried
to defend his pawn he got surprised
rick f8 is the only move queen takes e5
white's up has a pawn for the exchange
the two bishops
the initiative threats the knight can
come here now
and this is that's terrible okay so 96
trying to defend
f4 he played king h8 to avoid this
trick here f5 and now
this move actually isn't a bad move
according to the engine
it's not bad for us either because we
get to see more brilliance
but i don't like it because never
play f6
okay and luckily he did play f6
so we get to see a brilliant finish now
the engine
says every move wins every movie the
queen wins not moving the queen wins
but obviously taking the knights the
most brilliant and
if black was a computer he would just
take that and be dead lost
because white has two pieces um and a
pawn for a rook
so and his pieces are all terrible
so this move obviously loses so he's
like well if i'm a queen up
and white's attack doesn't work okay
that's not so bad
but yeah that's that ends the game
quickly white plays e7
it's amazing he sacrifices his queen on
e7
and if black takes it the pawn on e7
wins
black didn't take it then he sacks his
queen
again and then the pawn gets to e7 but
it's a different pawn
instead of the d pawn getting the e7
it's the f pawn amazing
okay well obviously this is checkmate so
the rook has to go somewhere
uh rook g8 is the best move
and after i take the rook you can't stop
me from queening
so i guess resigning is the best move
but he played rookie eight
and this is funny this is how difficult
chess is
white only has one winning move here but
it's really winning
it's winning winning not just winning
can you find it
i hope so rook f1 with
unstoppable rook f8 what's funny is it's
unstoppable
and yet black stopped it he resigned
and the computer announces made
everywhere but you have to move one of
these pawns
so when you lose your rook and the guy
queens you don't get mated right away
but it is nate moves unless black plays
badly then it's less than eight moves
i'll show you best play according to the
computer
best play for both sides h6 check
king h7 bishop g8 check let's go for a
walk
bishop f7 check uh king h7 lasts longer
than king f6
rook takes and now we're threatening
rook here check
queen chat queen g8 mate so you got to
move the g
pawn it doesn't matter if you go to g5
or g or g6
and then we do it anyway um
they both they're both mate and three it
doesn't matter but okay and then queen
and checkmate yeah now if white wasn't
checkmating black
it wouldn't matter because white's
completely winning here
so if there is no checkmate and there's
several it's still resignable
so an amazing game from maxie matlikov
against an i am i've never heard of but
now i've heard of him because he lost
this brilliant game
so there you go get something out of it
um
white sacrificed his queen black
declined
white sacrificed again and
game ended and you can you can attack
and sacrifice material
when your opponent's pieces are all
hiding on the queen side a very good
game from white
a tough game for black that's the way it
goes in chess
i'm grand master ben feingold for
chess.com's game of the day
please like and subscribe and watch more
of our videos
on game of the day thanks for watching
my video
bye everybody
[Music]
you